you've seen me play surgeon simulator
before but you asked for it in vr let's
play pee whoop okay oh
whoa i just started
there's a ringing phone
i'm gonna go ahead and pick that up
congratulations you've won a holiday for
two to pyongyang north korea oh i don't
want to go to north korea more details
no this sounds like spam uh
all right looks like there's a heart
transplant surgery that i need to do on
patient name bob i will say this is
pretty realistic for a medical thing
except that water bottle is not
excusable in here no what is this what
is this about diazepam
you can't have controlled substances
here oh okay we have a patient we have
tools there's a lot of blood on the
walls do i have guidance as to what i'm
supposed to do nope i'm grabbing the saw
and i'm going to start cutting gently
this area
because clearly we need to take out a
heart why is he bleeding chill chill
with the bleeding and why am i not
wearing gloves yeah
where's my assistant too
let's go ahead and put that down let's
go ahead and grab
oh i forgot this
you always forget the last rib
these aren't even anatomically correct
ribs by the way
okay usually we have like a container
for the ribs
just gonna go ahead and rest that
let go like no no let's go the heart is
beating the stomach is there the
esophagus is there the lungs are there
the liver is just chilling there's
pieces of ribs that we're gonna need to
reattach after the patient is is losing
blood but we have some blood here
can i reach for this
or no
oh yeah we oh
nope doesn't look like i can reach for
that do we want to record this
let's record this
yo we vlogging the surgery right now
my patient bob is doing really well
we're going to get the heart out please
like and subscribe okay we got that
let's see if i can oh you could just
take out his life his lungs aren't even
attached
this is a pretty realistic lung though
okay whoa that heart is blue that's not
a good sign we're gonna have to make
some incisions there what's the best way
to make it how do you turn off this saw
[Music]
i don't know
okay
my guy's just look at this my scalpel is
just floating on one finger okay i'm
gonna have to cut it like this
obviously there's a lot of bleeding i'm
cutting her heart let's just get rid of
this esophagus because this esophagus is
bothering me
oh i got the esophagus
i'm gonna go ahead and rest the
esophagus right here i cut the aorta
which is not good because my patient's
bleeding out i need to get my scalpel
again
okay looks like we got the heart nice
and cut let's go ahead and
get rid of that heart where's the other
heart is it in
here wait i need another heart he's
dying is there no heart
[Music]
there's got to be a heart he died
and it was going so well brutal murder
achieved in a mere
few seconds but wait where's the oh was
it in here
dang okay hold on give me another chance
let me just check if this is where the
heart is
oh [ __ ]
yo my bad bro i dropped your heart bob
let's just go ahead and re see if i feel
like if i put it in there that's going
to be a problem to get it out so you
want to keep it nice and slushy right
here
all right this is taking way too long
i'm going to use the oscillating bone
saw here
which by the way if you hit a patient
with a bone saw on their skin it doesn't
actually cut them because it just moves
very rapidly doesn't actually spin it
vibrates so it shouldn't technically cut
anything else so this is the safest
thing we can use to cut these bones
oh see that was misinformation right
there
whoa it's like
you think i can juggle this
oh [ __ ] i wonder if i can get sued for
this let's cut all the aorta okay we got
the heart loose we need to act quickly
here let's replace this broken heart
with the good heart uh
oh
look at all the balloons in my room
oh you can't kick them ready dunk on the
patient next mission let's learn about
our patient today we don't know age
needs a kidney transplant high risk for
blood loss well just practice writing
take
two and call
me
in
a
m
let's go ahead and sign this up oh we
got a phone call
yes
i picked up the whole phone
hello hello medical office
okay they don't care okay
we have a patient whose intestines are
exposed we have the large intestine
small intestine stomach liver lower
ribcage the patient has one toe larger
and longer than the rest that is not the
big toe let's see how our patient's
doing sir you okay okay we got him
knocked out let's do a little vlog yo we
here with bob bob messed up his heart
now we need to get bob's kidney so we're
about to get bob's kidney please like
and subscribe what up what up oh
i don't even know what this saw is for
but basically i'm gonna go ahead and
insert this right above the rectum it's
definitely very bloody
let me use two hands here
the large intestine refuses to be cut my
patient's bleeding out why does it feel
like the large intestine is like metal
what even is this a lightsaber
oh
it's a um
tool oh no my patient's bleeding out
pretty bad let's cauterize that maybe i
need to give him some of this
[Music]
how do you give syringes give it to him
in his face maybe
in his neck does that help oh no he's
bleeding a lot with that that's a blood
thinner oh i gave him the wrong one ah
brutal murder achieved okay i need to
restart this one anytime you have a
sharp in the field you want to be gentle
i say that as i'm cutting
through all of his organs oh he's
bleeding bad
i'm gonna go ahead and hold on to that
liver
oh oh no
oh no what am i looking at why is there
a video of me is it the stupid camera
quick
god there's so much so much intestine
here oh i dropped some stomach you just
we'll hang out right here oh oh
okay
one kidney
two kidneys where is the kidneys though
oh here
[Music]
oh
one kidney in
no
no
[Music]
my back hurts so much
okay they say when you fail get on the
horse and try again or
break the patient's ribs i think it
needs to be all scalpel driven yeah see
look at that
[Music]
look at that perfect cut
you don't even need to take out the ribs
that's what rookies do
see look at that you see what i'm saying
this is why you go to medical school you
throw the intestines away
you clear out the space that you need
whoa
chill
rectum let's get rid of the liver here
okay one kidney out two kidneys out this
is already looking more promising kidney
bean one sydney bean two
okay kidney one
oh
oh wait do you have to attach them or
something
no they're in
oh yeah
is that an a
is that an a i can't really see my
vision's blurry i'm sure he'll live
brain surgery
you know
when i was in med school that was the
easiest type of surgery patience still
bob
bob
what kind of lifestyle are you living
that all your organs are failing before
you start any brain surgery you always
have to start with a
pee
oh he's sitting yeah
oh
what just do i have to perform in the
dark
oh my god okay
so they made this oh there's the brain
that i'm gonna put in
so to make the cut
i'm gonna need to
see this isn't the right tool for this
job where's my oscillating saw here's my
oscillating saw
this is what you'd want to use for this
[Music]
yep
yep yep yep yep just like that and you
want to get through
gently
breaking through as if you're breaking
through a little egg i think i'm good
go ahead and put this down
okay whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
what is happening
do i have to cut it
oh and it just fell yo go oh i dropped
it okay but that's okay we can get this
fresh one go ahead and put this here
brain
slam dunk let's go
let's go
let me see anyone try and top that i'm
going to scratch my face with the
artificial hand as if it's my hand okay
let's begin the eyes well
first things first you're going to have
to remove the patient's goggles
[Music]
we need to take these out
[Music]
oh look there's eyes in here it's so
weird do i have to cut off these goggles
oh
oh look at that
look at that see sir can you tilt your
head just a little bit
you're really gonna stay in that
direction huh oh no i need you there you
go keep that eye open for me would ya
i'm gonna need to gently oh drop the
scissors on your lap sorry about that
sir let's go with the little
little sharp mini blade here
oh i left the scalpel inserted into your
eye
[Music]
okay it looks like i think i think i got
it loose
there you go
okay one eye out sir can you open up
your other eye
you want to make a cut right at the
retinal artery here you want to shake
the person's head get the eye loose and
then just make some gentle cuts
right at the eye
hanging there we go okay and then
basically what you want to do is you
want to empty out the spare eyes here
i'm assuming these are the right eyes
so i'm gonna go ahead and pop those back
in let's get rid of the right eye oh
actually that that was the left eye i
messed that up
okay
here we go
let's go ahead and pop that bad boy in
what's up hey
look at that
you see that those are the eyes i put in
for you
pay me your copay i actually did a whole
draw my life video about my story coming
to america click here to check it out
the animations are super fun and as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you